قلت الخارجيه الروسيه انها ابلغت الاطراف
المشاركه في اتفاق الحبوب بتمديده ل60
يوما فقط واضافت انه يمكن تمديده اذا تم
تنفيذه بالكامل وكانت الامم المتحده قد
اعلنت تمديدا الاتفاق وحثت جميع الاطراف
على مضاعفه الجهود من اجل تنفيذ المبادره
بالكامل واشارت الامم المتحده الى نقل نحو
25 مليون طن من الحبوب والمواد الغذائيه
الى خمس واربعين دوله خلال الفتلتين
الاوليين وهو ما ساهم في خفض اسعار الغذاء
عالميا وتحقيق الاستقرار في الاسواق
كما اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ان المباحثات التي قادتها بلاده نجحت في
تمديد اتفاقيه الحبوب بين الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني
المده المقرره والاتفاقيه الحبوب التي
اشرفنا عليها جنبا الى جنب مع الامم
المتحده وكانت من اهم ملفات التسويه التي
تم التوصل اليها منذ الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه تنتهي اليوم واود اعلامكم انه
بناء على المحادثات التي اجريناها مع
الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني فقد تقرر
تمديد تلك الاتفاقيه ومن المهم الاشاره
الى انه خلال هذه الاتفاقيه عبرت حوالي
800 باخره البحر الاسود ونقلت على متنها
اكثر من 25 مليون طن من الحبوب الى اسواق
العالم
معنى من الصبور المراسله الجزيره عمر
الحاج عمر ما هي الصيغه التي تم التوافق
عليها
لتمديد اتفاق الحبوب خصوصا
المده المختلف عليها
يعني حسن لابد من الاشاره ان الى ان هناك
نوع من الغموض وربما حتى التحفظ من قبل
كلي الاطراف بما فيها الوسيط التركي في
حديثي اردوغان الذي اشار اليه اشار فيه
الى تمديد هذه الاتفاقيه لم يتحدث عن
المده التي توصل توصل تركيا مع كلا
الجانبين الاوكراني والروسي لتمديد هذه
الاتفاقيه وهذا انعكس على تصريحات كلا
الجانبين الروسي والاوكرانية الاوكرى
الجانب الاوكراني يتحدث عن 120 يوما
والجانب روسيا يتحدث فقط عن 60 علما ان
اخر موعد اخر توقيت جددت في هذا الاتفاقيه
كانت في شهر اكتوبر من العام المنصرم
اردوغان يتحدث بعجاله عن هذا التجديد وقال
ان هذا التجديد كان نتيجه لجهود دبلوماسيه
بذلتها تركيا تواصل فيها الرئيس بنفسه مع
كل من نظيره الروسي اضافه الى اوكرانيا
واشار الى عدد السفن والكميه التي نقلت من
القمح والاسمده والحبو مختلفه خلال هذه
الفتره الوجيزه التي تصل الى ثمانيه اشهر
من تاريخ الاتفاق الذي اعلن في 22 من شهر
تموز المنصري مره اخرى هناك تفاين في
الارقام وسكوت او ربما تحفظ تركي عن هذه
المده وان كانت تركيا في اوقات سابقه
تتحدث عن ضروره تفعيل الاتفاقيه بكل
بنودها وان يكون الجانب الروسي ايضا له
حصه مشابهه لما للجانب الاوكراني من تصدير
الاسمده وتصدير الحبوب اذن تركيا بالاضافه
الى كونها الدوله الوسيطه والراعيه لهذا
الاتفاق كانت ايضا المسؤوله عن مسؤوله
فنيا عن هذا الاتفاق بتفتيش السفن الداخله
والخارجه من اوكرانيا حين كانت تحمل تحمل
الحبوب وايضا الذره والقمح الى الجهاز
المختلفه شكرا لك عمر الحاج حدثنا من
اسطنبول